warsmann a quitté l'allemagne s'est
installé à montréal il y a deux ans
parce que montréal est l'une des
capitales de la recherche sur la
tuberculose
l'une des meilleures équipes dans ce
genre de ligue
peu connu du grand public l'opportunité
pour ma carrière et pour reprendre une
métaphore sportive
l'équipe de chercheurs du centre
universitaire de santé mcgill et
l'université de montréal dans laquelle
travaille le docteur cartman vient de
gagner un match décisif qui pourrait les
mener en finale
nous sommes les premiers à montrer en
nouveaux chemins pour combattre la
tuberculose à entraînement des cellules
souches hématopoïétiques
ça veut dire en gros qu'on a trouvé
comment introduire dans l'organisme une
cellule qui agirait comme un entraîneur
de boxe et montrerait aux autres
cellules
comment mettre ko l'infection si le
docteur karl mann et si rayonnante c'est
que cette découverte a été publiée dans
la prestigieuse revue de sel au delà de
la gloire c'est surtout une avancée qui
lui permet d'espérer aboutir au vaccin
le vaccin pour l'instant testé sur des
souris mais s'il fonctionne sur les
humains cela pourrait changer le monde
bien sûr dans les pays du tiers-monde où
la tuberculose fait des ravages
mais ici aussi c'est une maladie qui
peut vivre sans faire aucun problème
pendant 40 ans et là soit on développe
un problème médical où on reçoit
médicaments qui supprime le système
immunitaire et là ça peut être développé
dans un intervalle de quelques mois et
ça peut causer même décès la tuberculose
est la seule maladie où le patient est
dans l'obligation légale de se faire
traiter
si on peut développer un vaccin ça peut
mettre fin par la maladie rapidement
jusqu'à maintenant la médecine mise donc
beaucoup sur sa défensive
montréal vient peut-être de lui
permettre de changer sa stratégie en lui
fournissant de nouvelles forces à
l'offensive
émilie dubreuil radio-canada horaire